I am so excited I am a huge 90-day
fiance fat and I couldn't think of
anybody better to be joining me on the
Canada bride right now Erica how are you
hi I'm good I'm just stuck in my room
well as to say congratulations being the
first gay couple really brought
visibility to 90-day fiance and that is
something to really be proud of tell me
what it means to you to bring that
visibility to 90 day fiancé I didn't
know what 90 day was before I went on it
because I'm like all the way Australian
like deep Australia couple of my sure I
was I was very overwhelmed but I was
also very proud I was like oh my god it
was really good it's a great feeling and
it's great to bring a little bit of
visibility not only to like a community
but a little bit of like five visibility
as well have you known about Stephanie's
health issues like it's crazy I have to
take this medication with me everywhere
I go because this is kind of what keeps
me alive
thus concerning problems with intimacy
you know telling me that you want to
have this next big relationship and
whatever and then on the other hand
you're essentially telling me like
you're not ready to be intimate and
that's really confusing you think you
would have continued that relationship
would it have gotten to the point of
going on 90 day fiancé if she was
upfront about those things we had what
anything to do with her health that we
want being intimate really in terms of
sex not not a huge deal at all despite
what it may have seemed sorry I mean I
would have I would have just continued
like we did yeah sadly didn't work out
but is there anything else you'd like to
talk about yeah I think I've said
everything that I want to say
but I'm curious as a fan because I did
get so invested in your relationship are
you two still in touch are you friend
and that's a complicated question like
having an ex is one thing and having an
x-ray entire relationship is shown on
television like that like like a
completely other thing but I mean we
talk sometimes mainly about 90 day stuff
not really not really always on the best
times what anyone who does something on
television I'm watching yourself that
can be a very difficult thing so like
this date is actually over know what
well you get just like seriously oh
let's go I'm not your precise gosh yeah
like yes
[Music]
we're very moments that you kind of were
watching that you cringe at watching oh
yeah if I get myself Sega with free
spirit ever again I'm probably gonna
like just going to hiding and never
return you are a pre fear it and that's
what I love about yeah yeah I guess like
in in most ways I am but just like when
someone said that out loud it it was
just it's cringe I did not love that and
also I didn't realize I did this until
all fans said it like continually
putting it out but I smack my lips all
the time and now I noticed that what you
wouldn't I feel myself doing it now and
I'm like you ever do something like this
again like would you look for love
online again oh that's it that's a tough
question
honestly I I'm not even like thinking
about finding love again just because
not because I'm like working there are a
lot of people out there who do struggle
with their sexuality and their own
coming-out journey we saw you come out
your parents on the show Steph is
actually here as my partner
[Music]
I'm bisexual
it's not a worry to have for a parent
it's just a that's just information it's
information that's all you got one of
these in your face that's the main thing
right
for anyone who is within the lgbtq+
community who may be struggling with who
they are or their own coming out journey
what advice would you give to them well
I know that not everyone has the same
experience I do so I think it's
important to recognize that you don't
need to have the acceptance from other
people to be able to like love yourself
and accept who you are I think it's
important to speak your truth because of
course it will affect your relationships
in the long run exactly how it did with
Stephanie and I but at the end of the
day what matters is like how you
perceive yourself and you're never gonna
be able to love yourself fully and I was
gonna be able to be exactly who you are
without you know accepting that are we
gonna see some drama on the towel this
Sunday in their drama should I be ready
for that I can't give away too much
obviously but you'll see you'll see oh
hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos